I remember the first time when I step on  the pedal  I love how quiet it is I love how  seamless it is how it pulls you and that  speed and that power in that torque the  favorite features that I continue to  love about Tesla is it's the software  updates it's the feeling that you know  your car is always new I felt so safe  inside everything was set up and  everything was so easy I personally  really like using the app as well I can  always check with her no I need to  charge the car  driving in Hong Kong is pretty hectic  there are a lot of cards coming in and  out I think it's so hard to Hong Kong to  find a peace of mind no matter if you're  on the bus or even with a car with an  engine with the toddler makes it so much  easier especially with the auto pilot on  the highways it's almost like to me it's  like swimming you find that piece and  then you can kind of hear that in the  voice of yours  you will always remember it you will  always remember that feeling  [Music]